In the midst of our suffering it's easy to feel alone, to feel isolated.
When
we see or experience suffering it's natural to ask a lot of questions.
Why am I suffering? Am I alone? Is my suffering going to end?
Why is God allowing me to suffer?
Where is God when I suffer and what is Christianity's unique response to
suffering and pain.
Let me share a story that might help.
In 1873, a priest by the name of Father Damien heard about a colony
of lepers who were living and dying without anybody to care for them.
So with full awareness of the risk, Father Damien went and became a priest
for this colony of lepers he prayed for them he preached to them he changed
their wounds he built caskets he buried many of them for 12 years with deep
compassion and care he loved this colony of lepers so they would know and
experience the love of God one Sunday evening however everything
changed father Damien stood before the people with leprosy and he spoke these
two words he said, we lepers. He opened up his robe and showed
the first physical signs of leprosy.
Father Damien had become a leper.
Let me ask you a couple questions about the story.
First, how did the view of the lepers change towards Father Damien when he
became a leper? No doubt beforehand they knew that he loved them.
They saw his willingness to sacrifice everything for them, but now when he got
leprosy everything was different.
Now he could understand them in a new way.
They saw the depth of his sacrifice for them.
He could empathize with them in a personal way.
The second question is, is God's response to our suffering more like Father Damien
before he got leprosy or after? And if we stop and we think about the
life, ministry, and death of Jesus, I think the answer is clear.
It's after. See, God didn't just send a prophet or an angel or a book as important
as those are. In the person of Jesus Christ, God came down personally
and has experienced our pain. We are not abandoned to our suffering and our
pain. So part of the answer to where is God when I suffer, is that God is right
there suffering with us.
Think about the symbols for the various world religions.
Got the statue of Buddha for Buddhism, the gate for Shintoism, the
crescent and the sword for Islam, or the star of David for Judaism.
Yet for Christianity, the most defining image, the most defining symbol is the
cross. A picture of the creator of the universe stepped down in human flesh,
suffering for us. We follow and worship a God who has suffered.
Isaiah the prophet said the coming Messiah would be a man of sorrows, familiar with
suffering.
And the book of Hebrews, the author of Hebrews writes in chapter 4 that we do not
follow a high priest who's unable to sympathize with us, But we have a high priest
who's been tempted and tested in every way like we are.
He understands our weaknesses, but is without sin.
If you're ever tempted to think that God doesn't understand your suffering or your
pain, you might think again. For example, if you're in physical pain and you think,
gosh, I'm in so much pain, God doesn't understand what I'm going through.
Remember, Jesus was crucified and experienced excruciating physical
pain. if you've gone through relational difficulties and maybe somebody's betrayed
you or left you out and you think god you don't understand remember during his
lifetime much of jesus family didn't believe in him and in fact he was betrayed by
one of his closest disciples jesus understands
many times what our suffering enables us to do is to have empathy for other people
and build a deeper sense of community.
Take the example of Father Damien contracting leprosy, as painful and as
hurtful as that is. That enabled him to be into a new community and experience the
love of a people that wasn't there before.
Ultimately I might not be able to explain why you or me or anyone else
experiences a particular kind of suffering.
Sometimes we might know in this life, but many times it won't be until we get to
eternity. But I know this. I know that God is good.
I know that God has not abandoned us in our suffering.
I know God is asking you and me the same question he asked Job thousands of years
ago when Job was suffering immensely.
He said, Job, will you trust me?
It's important to remember that God can take our greatest pain, our greatest
suffering, and turn it to good. We see this in the life of Joseph, a story that you
know. Joseph is sold into slavery from his own brothers, ends up in prison,
but rises up through God's hand to be second in command in Egypt and is able to save
his family from famine. When he finally talks with his brothers and they realize his
identity, they're afraid that he might have retribution against them.
But what does he say? He essentially says, don't worry.
What you meant for evil, God meant for good.
When Jesus was arrested and crucified, his apostles thought that all
had been lost. This movement and person they had been following for roughly
three years seemingly had come to an end.
They were devastated. But what they didn't realize at that moment is in their
darkest hour, God had never let go of the steering wheel.
He was still in control and working his greatest good.
We see it's through the resurrection that we know that death does not have the end.
Suffering is not the end. And that this world will ultimately be
redeemed.
Suffering and pain do not have the final word.
Jesus is risen. That's right, Jesus is risen.
That's why the Apostle Paul, who experienced tremendous suffering, could shout with
an air of defiance in 1 Corinthians 15, a chapter on the resurrection.
Death, where's your victory? Death, where's your sting?